um so la was it last year you did the
Ice protest
show oh no that was a few years back man
was that did you end up going cuz I know
you did something downtown LA but did
you end up going to like the Border you
were doing like a show outside of the
Border in San Diego right yeah yeah and
I went to Mexico um by so you you in but
I went to uh yeah I went to TJ and I
went to an actual like ice Detention
Facility and performed outside of it on
a truck I was going to say it was on a
truck right yeah I remember seeing that
and I I DJ in San Diego all the time and
I go get all my medicine from Tijana so
I know how crazy that border especially
cuz what what year was this was this
2020 19
maybe yeah that border during the Trump
years was [__] crazy it was crazy yo
there was so many people like it was
nuts and I think when we went over there
to get in like one of the
um what was the big like immigrant like
uh there like there was a lot of people
trying to seek asylum in the US and they
were stopped at in Tijana in TJ a lot of
African people that something that I
didn't know until I went there yeah I
mean just the way that they were running
that situation was just like super
inhumane and I was really surprised to
see so many African people like West
African people I think they were from
like Cameroon or Congo there were some
frenchspeaking Africans and it was like
you know hundreds upon hundreds of
people and the way that they
would get contacted was like they get to
the front of this line of thousands of
people and then they give them a number
on a piece of paper and then they call
that number sometime within the next
month like weeks on weeks and you
literally have to be within earshot to
hear your number called to at the border
at the border so you kind of have to
just hang out there for months like to
proceed to the we're going to sleep on
this sidewalk exactly what they were
doing it was like it was gross
definitely to see the way that they were
treating human beings like I was I was
really taken back by that but that's
also in the midst of like all the things
happening with the kids in the detention
facilities I just remember seual ass
cages blankets that were like like
metallic aluminum foil aluminum foil
blanket and I think a lot of that
stuff's still going on right now it's
definitely still going on yeah cuz I
mean I you know I I was I'm definitely a
[__] Donald Trump type of guy but I
think a lot of that [__] was going on
before him too and after and after you
mean I'm I'm not making any excuses for
him in particular but you know what I'm
saying the uh hypocrisy of like American
oppression doesn't begin or end with
Donald Trump Donald Trump is just the
one to put it on Front Street he said
this actually what I'm on I'm paying all
my [__] I'm here for the bag straight
like that [__] y'all this is what
presidents have been doing the whole
time Donald Trump just said what he was
on you know he just let y'all know what
was going down he said what he was on
that's why you know it's crazy too
because like I've like been like a
lifelong like you know liberal Democrat
guy like you know I voted for Joe Biden
but this last [__] few years I just
been like I just don't know where we go
from here like I don't know like how do
you feel about this next presidential
election because it really feels like
somehow we're going to end up with the
same two guys and I don't know if either
of them are great for our country and I
just don't you know neither of them are
great no they're definitively terrible
neither of them is great Joe Biden has
been a terrible president and I voted
for him he just hasn't been great um but
the guy before him was terrible for his
own re terrible for the racial division
the normalization of lot of things like
him getting locked up and having that
hard ass mug shot too I think that only
helps his CH bro I'm like it's going to
be a Griselda album cover event like
Westside gun's next album cover might be
the Donald
Trump M unfortunately that's only
helping his case that's what I'm tell
I'm like yo these guys if they're going
to go all in they better make sure they
better slam him cuz if he don't go to
jail he's going to be the next president
he can't even run he can run from jail
and he will but I think he'll lose the
primary cuz I think there's enough I
think he'll lose but uh I can't call it
call it I can't call it I mean
like Joe Biden
to I'm not going to forget that Joe
Biden is responsible for the 1994 crime
bill yeah yeah the crime Bill and called
called the system of mass incarceration
as we know it there's Millions he also
nipped the uh HBCU bill that uh was
supposed to fund a lot of the HBCU that
was I think I think Trump put that
through yeah Biden is listen man that's
why I'm like I don't know where what do
we do do we I'm like I told everybody I
was just talking to my U my wife's uh
mom and I said if it's Trump versus
Biden or if it's like the santis vers
Biden I'm just going to vote Cornell
West and [__] sleep well at West no
Cornell I know I
heard um what if Cornell West and Kanye
West ran on a on a double bill um yo
shout out to Kanye who was definitely
just getting blown in the middle of a
boat in Italy and it's that that was
what we thought it was right okay okay
his ass was out were down bro I didn't
see that part I didn't see that part um
yeah this NE this next election I can't
call it man I don't know if I would vote
for Biden again I mean honestly I think
that it's always a lesser of two evils
situation but sometimes it's hard to
really determine what the lesser of the
two evils are a lot of the guys the guys
want Trump because he gave him PPP loans
but was going crazy shows you how simple
[__] be man it's like you dangle that
carrot in front of them gave him them
PPP loans and you know they they want
them back for real